- Have you ever been hit by a sports ball?
- I have.
I have been hit at a Major
League Baseball game.
I'll set the scene for you,
I was on third base side.
So that's right where third base is.
First, second, third, home.
Third base side, guy hit a line drive,
which means straight across.
There was nothing that broke,
like, where the ball was coming.
The security guard that was with me
actually ducked when it came my way
and I went like this
and it smacked me, clear
as day, in the mouth.
There it is!
Hot.
- [Kelly] Holy moly!
(audience murmurs)
- It bounced off my face
and landed behind me, but I was fine.
Doctor said I had a jaw
still, you know what I mean?
- Oh, my gosh!
That, I would brag about that.
- Yeah.
- I would brag about that.